ein solcher gammastrahlenausbruch könnte
das leben auf der erde nahezu komplett
zerstört und es gibt thesen dass das
schon einmal passiert ist hier auf
unserem heimatplaneten genauer vor 440
millionen jahren könnte es zum
zweitgrößten artensterben geführt haben
droht uns jetzt diese katastrophe wieder
klicks und science fiction bei uns gibt
es täglich wissenschafts videos aber und
jeden kanal dann verpasst er keins mehr
herzlich willkommen vielen dank für den
themenvorschlag auf whatsapp wolfram
jetzt sterne haben alle eines gemeinsam
es sind ehemalige große sterne die sehr
massereich und kurzlebig sind und
irgendwann einmal kollabieren bei dieser
supernovaexplosion wird von beiden polen
extrem mit gamma strahlung ausgesendet
und die ist tödlich wenn ein bewohner
planet in diesen strahlt gerät vor 440
millionen jahren könnte es bei der erde
der fall gewesen sein und um solch eine
gammastrahlen bombe handelt es sich auch
bei dem wolf riot stern namens wer 104
im sternbild schütze und astronomie
teams sind sich einig wer 104 wird
demnächst explodieren hinweise dazu
liefert sein spektrum das auf eine
starke instabilität schließen lässt
konkret handelt es sich bei wr 104 um
ein doppelsternsystem zum einen aus
einem ball frei jetzt stern ein
ehemaliger großer stern der seine
atmosphäre ins all geblasen hat und von
dem quasi nur noch der heiße kern übrig
ist er liegt im sternbild schütze und
ist etwa 8000 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt bis zu 100 andere wolf reihen
sterne die sich über die milchstraße
verteilen sind uns bislang bekannt
typischerweise stößt so ein stern ein
extrem starken sternen wind aus der bis
zu 2000 kilometer pro sekunde schnell
sein kann ein großer stern kann durch
stern wind das mehrfache der erdmasse
pro jahr verliert wahlfreiheit sterne
sind sehr viel schwerer als die sonne
sie können tatsächlich bis zum 200
fachen der sonnenmasse wiegen ihre
oberflächentemperatur ist zudem sehr
heiß und zwar bis zu 100.000 kelvin im
vergleich dazu sind die 5500 kelvin der
sonne ja fast lächerlich zum anderen
besteht das system aus einem sternen
begleiter vom spektral
der deutlich weniger masse hat der
extrem starke wind der vom wall freiheit
stern abgeht tritt auf dem wind seines
begleiters so dass eine stoßwelle
entsteht der sternen wind verdichtet
sich extrem dadurch entsteht eine menge
staub denn der wahlfreiheit stern wind
ist der kohlenstoff reich der staub
selbst ist warm und kann daher gut im
infraroten beobachtet werden doch auch
das ist eigentlich ein merkwürdiges
phänomen denn in der nähe eines solchen
sterns ist es viel zu heiß und 11 die
strahlung würde die staubpartikel
eigentlich zerstören doch dort wo die
sternwinde der beiden sterne
aufeinandertreffen
da ist es tatsächlich kühl genug damit
sich staub bilden kann wie das mit den
temperaturen rund um sternen sterne sich
welt das weiß man ja immer noch nicht so
ganz genau deswegen ist ja jetzt eine
sonde unterwegs zusammen dass sich die
beiden sterne selbst umeinander bewegen
entsteht letztendlich dann das spiral
muster aus staub acht monate braucht das
system um sich einmal um sich selbst zu
drehen und die todesspirale umfasst
zudem wohl unglaubliche 160
astronomische einheiten und das ist
wirklich kaum zu glauben denn damit ist
die knapp doppelt so groß wie unser
sonnensystem damit man es sich besser
vorstellen kann hier mal vergleich unser
sonnensystem bis hinaus zum neptun hat
nur einen radius von 30 astronomischen
einheiten von freiheit sterne sind die
hellsten und größten der uns bekannten
sterne
sie sind sogar 10 bis 2 150 sonnenmassen
groß zudem haben sie wie gesagt den
größten teil der atmosphäre schon
abgestoßen
wenn die sterne sterben entsteht
mindestens eine supernova explosion
eventuell sogar eine deutlich stärkere
supernova aus den polen des
sternschießen lang gammastrahlen heraus
und genau das könnte zu einem großen
problem für das leben auf der erde
werden denn bei eintritt eines solchen
gammablitze auf die erdatmosphäre würde
sich die ozonschicht wohl auflösen und
das hätte weitreichende konsequenzen für
das leben auf der erde
denn die ozonschicht schützt unsere
lebewesen hier auf der erde vor der
gefährlichen uv strahlung und dieser
schutz wäre dann nicht mehr gegeben wir
würden quasi hier verbrennen so viel
sonnencreme können was ich gar nicht
auftragen um sich davor zu schützen
immer wieder mal haben forschungsteams
weltweit wer 100 wir deswegen im blick
denn eine entfernung von 8000 litern
bedeutet im weltall nicht wirklich die
welt der 2018 hieß es dann dass die
rotationsachse des doppelsternsystems
direkt auf unser sonnensystem zeigt und
er in den nächsten 100 jahren
explodieren könnte ok entspannung dauert
noch die große frage aber trotzdem
könnten uns die gammastrahlenblitze hier
auf der erde treffen und im schlimmsten
fall das leben vernichten astronomie
team sind sich mittlerweile einig dass
keine direkte gefahr von mehr als 4
ausgeht denn inzwischen sind neue bilder
von dem jahr im jahr 1998 entdeckten
doppelsternsystem entstanden und diese
zeigen dass die erde eben nicht exakt
auf seine pole zeigt oder dem strahl
liegen könnte der dann entsteht wir
werden also voraussichtlich nicht
getroffen trotzdem bieten uns
wahlfreiheit sterne die tolle
möglichkeit mehr über große sterne zu
erfahren die staub spirale von veranda 4
zeigt uns wo wir herkommen denn auch
unsere erde besteht genau wie wir
menschen aus kohlenstoff und anderen
schweren elementen die vor langer zeit
mal vom großen stern erzeugt wurden wenn
er übrigens alle videos als erste sehen
wollt dann abonniert auch den englischen
kanal von krieg zum science fiction hier
einfach draufklicken da gibt es immer
wieder auf - zuerst wie zum beispiel
food made by some like einfach da
drunter drauf klicken und los geht's bis
dann bleibt dran